the genetic material is stored in the
form of DNA in most organisms in humans
the nucleus of each cell contains over
three into ten days for nine base pairs
of DNA distributed over 23 pairs of
chromosomes each cell has two copies of
this genetic material this collectively
is known as the human genome the human
genome contains about 30,000 genes each
of which codes for certain proteins
although thousands of genes in the human
DNA code for proteins large stretches of
DNA in the human genome are transcribed
but they do not code for proteins these
regions are known as introns and they
make up about 95% of the genome
some of this non-coding DNA control gene
expression but the purpose of much of it
is not yet understood this is a
fascinating subject that is certain to
advance rapidly over the next few years
so we know that all the information of
the human genome is coded in the DNA in
genes in the form of nucleotide base
pairs how this coded information is used
to produce functional products like
proteins is known as gene expression and
it essentially consists of two important
steps the first involves copying of the
coded information in DNA to RNA molecule
which takes place inside the nucleus of
the cell and this is known as
transcription this RNA molecule then
leaves the nucleus and the information
of this RNA molecule is used to produce
functional gene products like proteins
and this step is known as translation in
this video we will take a brief look on
the process of transcription make sure
to subscribe for upcoming video on
translation you can also take a look at
our previous videos on DNA structure and
DNA replication links are in the
description below
so the process of transcription takes
place in two broad steps first the
enzyme RNA polymerase forms a pre
messenger RNA molecule this happens in
the nucleus by using base pairs
complementary to the base sequence of
the DNA template strand in the second
part the pre mRNA is edited by more
enzymes to produce a desired mRNA which
is the final product of the
transcription so let's look at the first
section of this process which is the
formation of the pre messenger RNA which
essentially takes place in three steps
initiation elongation and termination
now the main enzyme that is involved in
this process of transcription is the RNA
polymerase the RNA polymerase has the
main job of copying the information of
the DNA to a new RNA molecule RNA
polymerase builds the new strand from
the five prime to the three prime
direction adding new nucleotides to the
three prime end so the first step in the
formation of a pre messenger RNA
molecule is the initiation in which the
enzyme RNA polymerase binds to the
promoter region of the DNA now let's
suppose this is a gene that is shown in
the green that needs transcription at
the beginning of each gene there is a
sequence of base pairs known as the
promoter region of the gene the promoter
region serves as a guide which tells the
enzyme RNA polymerase where to attach
once the RNA polymerase binds to the
promoter region it separates these two
strands of DNA providing the
single-stranded template needed for
transcription only one of these strands
is used in the process of transcription
which is known as a template strand this
strand always runs from the three prime
to the five prime direction this is
because of the fact that we just
discussed that is that RNA polymerase
can only synthesize the new strand from
the five prime to three prime direction
so it can only use a strand of the DNA
running from the three prime to five
prime direction as a template as a new
strand that is copied is always copied
in the anti parallel direction so after
the RNA polymerase binds to the promoter
region of the DNA the second step in
this process is elongation which is the
process of copying the bases on the DNA
template strand to form
new complementary RNA strand the RNA
polymerase uses nucleotides according to
the base pair complimentary rules to
create RNA copy in the previous videos
we learn how the DNA is copied by DNA
polymerase to form an identical new
strand of DNA in that case the DNA
polymerase added the base thymine when
the template strand had the base adenine
and it added the base cytosine when the
template strand showed the base guanine
and vice-versa but in case of
transcription the RNA molecule that is
produced contains the base uracil
instead of thymine so there are no T's
in the base pair sequence of RNA
whenever the RNA polymerase detects the
base adenine in the template strand
it adds uracil in the forming RNA strand
so this is how the enzyme RNA polymerase
adds new base pairs in the three prime
end of the growing RNA chain and this is
known as elongation
the next step is domination so just like
we had a sequence of gene known as the
promoter region which signaled the
enzyme where to start
we have regions of the gene that
basically signal the enzyme where to
stop these signals are known as
terminators and the signal that the RNA
transcript is now complete once the RNA
polymerase reads and transcribe the
Terminator regions the newly formed RNA
transcript is released from the
transcription complex
so this was the first section of this
process in which the DNA is used to
produce RNA molecule this RNA is known
as the pre mRNA or the pre messenger RNA
the prefix is used here to show that
this mRNA is not yet ready to leave the
nucleus and start the process of
translation so the next section of this
process of transcription deals with how
this pre mRNA is converted to a mature
RNA molecule so imagine that you want to
publish a new book and you have printed
all the pages now you cannot sell the
book yet because the new book needs
covers both front and back also before
selling it it is important to check for
any blank or wrong pages that may have
been inserted these two processes
essentially represent how the pre mRNA
is processed the first step involves
addition of a cap and a tail to the ends
of this pre messenger RNA molecule these
caps and tails are short amino acid
sequences that protect the pre mRNA
molecule the free ends of the pre mRNA
are liable to attack from many enzymes
the cap and the tail covers these ends
the second step of this process involves
removal of any unuseful or junk
sequences that do not code for proteins
and these are known as introns this is
known as RNA splicing in which the
protein RNA complex known as the
spliceosome removes these non-coding
parts the rest of the DNA is then joined
again together to create a mature RNA
molecule so this was a brief look at the
process of transcription guys thank you
so much for watching this video if you
found this video and all the other free
educational videos on this channel
helpful you can now support meThe
simplified on patreon.com for literally
the price of a coffee cup this will
allow me to fund my work and make more
videos like this and will also unlock
some cool patreon only exclusive content
like behind-the-scenes of these videos
upcoming videos early notifications and
exclusive flash cards and handouts make
sure to subscribe us on YouTube for all
the upcoming videos and also make sure
to follow us on Instagram and Facebook
for flashcards notifications and much
more